even the worst person can occasionally
do a good thing in the movies that
happens with some regularity keep
watching for some bad guys who redeem
themselves a little at least
few mcu characters undergo such radical
evolution as thor's adopted brother loki
and many fans would agree that loki
switched from super villain to superhero
a while ago but in 2013's thor the dark
world he's still fresh from his mass
murder and avengers if nothing else is
proof that he's still got a toe in the
dark side there's his aid to curse
during the dark elf assault on asgard
and his subjugation of odin at the end
of the film while we still see a more
heroic side to the trickster god in the
dark elf world when thor attempts to
destroy the ether with his lightning
loki rushes to shield jane foster from
any harm moments later when curse lobs
one of the black hole grenades of the
heroes loki nearly sacrifices himself to
push jane out of the way finally when
curse proves too powerful for thor to
handle alone it's loki's deceit that
kills the dark elf after he secretly
attaches a black hole grenade to the
monster
in 1983's return of the jedi luke
skywalker rejects the repeated advice of
yoda and obi-wan who insists there is no
salvation possible for darth vader luke
willingly surrenders himself to imperial
forces believing anakin skywalker is
still alive within vader vader brings
luke to palpatine and ultimately luke
must once more duel his father but this
time his victory nearly pushes him to
the dark side in the end luke's faith
then his father is redeemed as palpatine
tortures luke with force lightning vader
looks back and forth between his son and
the emperor eventually choosing what no
one expects but everyone prays for
rather than let his son die he lifts
palpatine from the floor and battered by
the emperor's lightning hurls his former
master down a long shaft in the end
anakin not only saves his son but proves
he really is the chosen one the late
qui-gon jinn knew he was so many years
ago
in 2004 spider-man 2 auto octavius aka
doc ock proves to be a much more
sympathetic villain than his predecessor
green goblin after the robotic arms he
initially uses only to aid him in his
scientific pursuits are fused to his
body we learn the arms possess a
malevolent intelligence which begins
influencing everything octavius does
octavius is transformed into an obsessed
monster who will do anything including
kill to realize his scientific goals
thankfully by the end of the film
octavius is able to emerge from the
arm's influence and redeem himself in
the climax octavius's experimental
fusion reactor is going wild and
endangering not only spider-man and mary
jane but the entire city finally able to
assert his dominance over the robot arms
octavius uses them to save new york by
plunging the reactor into the east river
the last we see of him octavius's
seemingly lifeless body follows the
reactor toward the bottom of the river i
will not die a monster
long before they introduced us to the
dude of the big lebowski joel and ethan
cohen gave audiences the 1990 gangster
film miller's crossing gabriel byrne
stars as tom reagan a high-ranking
advisor in the irish mob who goes rogue
when his boss starts to get edged out of
business by his italian rival the
unpredictable johnny casper tom's risky
gambit is a long con confusing both
brendan and foe alike so he can win
casper's confidence and destroy him from
the inside through sheer relentlessness
one person is able to sniff out tom's
game casper's brutal right-hand man
eddie dain aka the dane toward the end
of the film thomas summoned to casper's
home where the dane waits to kill him at
first casper goes along with the dane's
plans doing nothing as he chokes the
life out of tom but just as tom begins
to fade casper crushes the dane's nose
with a fireplace shovel saving tom and
yelling that it was the dane who
double-crossed him minutes later casper
says to tom look at this kid something i
try to teach all my boys he strides over
to his desk gets a gun and shoots the
dane in the
one in head
brain
for much of 2017's thor ragnarok scourge
isn't particularly impressive not only
is he the only warrior at the bifrost
who doesn't lift a hand to stop hello
when she arrives in asgard but even
after he becomes her so-called
executioner he pretty much just feels
hella's evil monologues and lets the
army of the dead and fenris do all the
heavy lifting in the final battle rather
than commit to either side skurge
disguises himself and boards the refugee
ship hoping to escape however after hela
summons one of her spikes to stop the
refugee ship and her undead minions
begin pouring into the vessel scourge
finally finds his courage he unveils his
beloved rifles des and troy and mows
down the unliving soldiers before they
can overtake the ship sacrificing his
own escape for that of his brethren
scourge leaps from the ship and fights
off the army of the dead as the ship
pulls away like his comic book
counterparts heroic glass stand in
1985's thor number 362 scourge
ultimately dies for asgard as helic
kills him once she sees he switch sides
one of the most memorable scenes in
1993's jurassic park is the unveiling of
the gargantuan t-rex after escaping her
enclosure she takes one of the first
human victims of the film when she
devours the lawyer on the toilet she
comes close to killing hammond's
grandkids when she nudges their car off
a ledge and injures the chaos theorist
ian malcolm enough to keep him on his
back for the rest of the film but in the
end it's the t-rex who proves to be the
hero's salvation in the film's final act
hammond's grandchildren are hunted by
the deadly velociraptors in the visitor
center ellie and grant do their best to
help the children but eventually all
four of them are trapped by two of the
hungry beasts in the center's main room
just as one of the raptors is about to
strike the t-rex reappears snatches it
off the floor with its jaws kills it and
begins eating it as the second raptor
attacks the t-rex the heroes take the
opportunity to escape
in the 1988 action comedy midnight run
everybody wants to capture the fugitive
accountant jonathan mardukis the
luckless bounty hunter jack walsh has
marduk is in custody for most of the
film but they're pursued by the fbi
special agent alonzo moseley the mob and
rival bounty hunter marvin dorfler in
texas walsh and mardukas are cornered by
two mob goons the heroes find an
unlikely savior in the form of the
brutal marvin dorfler who knocks both
goons out the butt of his shotgun also
has no intention of giving his bounty up
to dorfloor so he handcuffs himself to
mardukas and seemingly throws away the
key dwarfler loads them bolt into his
car and they soon find themselves
pursued by a helicopter with a gangster
sharpshooter on board eventually things
get desperate enough that walsh
convinces dorfler to give him a gun and
the former takes out the chopper with a
shot to the tail rotor as dorfler
celebrates their salvation walsh sucker
punches him knocking him unconscious
dissimilar to the marvel comics it's
rare that x-men's old enemy magneto
would ally himself with his rivals or
ever join their team the first time
something like this happens in the film
adaptations however is in the aptly
named x2 x-men united after a
confrontation with the boston police
turns violent outside bobby drake's home
the x-men's blackbird is pursued by a
pair of fighter jets by dialing her
powers up to 11 storm is able to get
both pilots to eject but not before one
of them fires off two missiles gene
takes out one of the missiles with her
telekinesis but the second detonates
close enough to the blackbird to send it
spinning to the ground below as the jet
drops it inexplicably slows and finally
comes to a halt mere feet from the
ground from outside the jet we see
mystique and magneto with the latter
extending his arm and using his powers
to keep the jet from crashing as the
x-men begin to realize what's happened
magneto jokes the mystique when will
these people learn how to fly
in the 1993 romantic crime drama true
romance things change in a big way for
comic book store clerk clarence and
former sex worker alabama this is when a
combination of vigilante justice and
dumb luck deposits a suitcase full of
uncut cocaine in their laps they managed
to get wealthy movie producer lee
donowitz to take the drugs off their
hands for hefty sum and the deal takes
place in an expensive la hotel suite
unbeknownst to anyone else in the suite
donowitz's assistant elliott is working
as an informant for the lapd once the
deal is finalized the cops charge in but
donowitz's private security guards
refuse to stand down the standoff gets
more complicated when the mobsters who
want their drugs back burst into the
suite surprisingly the standoff turns
violent because of the unarmed donowitz
the producer goes wild when he realizes
elliot betrayed him and throws a trait
full of hot coffee in his assistant's
face detective nicholson opens fire in
response and soon everyone is shooting
elliott donowitz all of donovan's
security all the cops and almost all of
the mobsters quickly die one of the
gangsters makes it as far as the hotel
lobby where he's gunned down by uniform
police the only survivors are clarence
alabama and their friend dick though
clarence loses an eye in the exchange
who would have thought that a deadly
three-way shootout would become their
saving grace
in 2001's the lord of the rings the
fellowship of the ring during the hero's
trip through moria gandolf had some wise
words for frodo he tells him that he
should have pity on gollum as bilbo did
when he spared gollum's life years prior
gandalf believes gollum has a part to
play in their story still saying the
pity of bilbo
may rule the fate of men
the words prove prophetic more than once
first in spite of gollum's inevitable
betrayal frodo and sam would never have
made it to mordor without him second in
the two towers it's gollum who rescues
frodo when the hobbit is mesmerized by
the ghostly lights of the dead marshes
and nearly drowns finally there's the
destruction of the one ring when he
finally makes it to mount doom like the
humane seal door before him frodo is
overcome by the ring and decides to keep
it he puts it on immediately drawing the
attention of sauron in his wraiths it's
only because of gollum's timely
intervention chomping frodo's finger off
that sauron is defeated in the struggle
that follows both frodo and gollum fall
over the edge while sam saves frodo
gollum descends into the lava below
dying and taking the ring with him it
may not have been gollum's virtuous
intention but his lust for the ring
became the salvation for many his
accidental sacrifice not only saved
proto from the ring's power but also the
rest of the world
the replicant roy does some terrible
things in the 1982 sci-fi classic blade
runner but in the film's climax he
chooses to save the life of deckard
despite the fact that he is the hero who
is not only hunting him but has already
killed two of the three replicants who
worked with roy including his lover
priss after priss's death roy pursues
deckard through the bradbury building
knowing he only has minutes to live and
presumably resolving to take deckard
with him deckard manages to escape the
building to the rooftops but loses his
gun in the process unarmed in facing the
super strong roy deckard has no choice
but to flee across the rooftops but he's
no spider-man his jump is short on the
way from one roof to the other and he
begins slipping from the opposite ledge
rather than letting him fall roy easily
leaps to the ledge waits until deckard
finally loses his grip and grabs a blade
runner's wrist with one hand roy lifts
deckard and deposits him to safety in
his final moments roy tells deckard
about some of the amazing things he's
seen in space regretting that those
moments will be lost in time like tears
in the rain considering his words it
seems likely roy chose to save his
opponent not out of forgiveness or any
sudden surge of moral righteousness
rather because as a man seconds from
death he values life even that of an
enemy more than vengeance check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movie bad guys are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]